when I turn overseas where American
marines are launching a new fight in
Afghanistan to help fight for territory
they once held the Taliban is back in
control of the Helmand province where
349 Marines were killed between 2001 and
2014 Charlie d'Agata joined the Marines
on their renewed mission good morning
when US Marines left Helmand province
back in 2014 it was thought they had the
job done but not long after they left
the Taliban fought back reclaiming a lot
of that territory now the Marines are
back and we joined them on what's become
a very different mission the last time
US Marines were in Helmand province they
were a fighting force numbering in the
tens of thousands we had back then
Brigadier General Roger Turner was a
colonel did you think he'd be back here
no I didn't we knew that the mission was
gonna end in in 2014 so I didn't think
I'd be back here now he is back but this
time his mission is dramatically
different now he's in command of just
300 Marines training Afghans to fight
for themselves we join them as they flew
over Taliban held territory about the
only way American forces can safely move
now this was one of my positions this
undisclosed location used to be a US
Marine base how hard of a fight do you
think this is gonna be now that fight is
down to Afghan Brigadier General wali
Muhammad Ahmad's I who stressed the
urgent need for increased American
support this war is not just ours he
said it's a war against international
terrorism we had more forces here we'd
be able to to partner down at lower
levels and you can achieve results
faster we could use the numbers we could
use the numbers in the right places
American and Afghan commanders admit
this new strategy is going to take more
time but the hope is this time Afghan
forces will be able to hold on to that
territory
they've recaptured from the Taliban for
CBS this morning Charlie d'Agata Kabul